dear Norah the question that you're
asking is very important what is the
connection between globalization and the
quality of education and i would say
that many of the efforts to improve the
quality of education around the world
are really efforts to improve the
efficiency of education in achieving the
goals of the past and what globalization
has done is change the context around
educational institutions in ways that
demand a very different set of skills
from graduates of elementary secondary
schools and universities and what are
those skills those are the skills in the
first place to understand this new
global order that is being created as a
result of telecommunications
technologies migration enhanced forms of
trade and they need for global
institutions that can enhance and
sustained global security and peace and
in the creation of these new civic space
global civic space it is absolutely
indispensable that every citizen around
the planet has the skills to understand
that space to support it and to
participate in it effectively so one of
the demands one of the consequences of
globalization for education systems is
that they should all be aligning their
curriculum be aligning their goals to
promote global competency and that
involves the competency to be an active
global citizen to be in some cases an
effective global leader and to have the
skills to participate in an increasingly
global economy what does it mean that
means that education systems need to
produce three things first of all they
need to produce the kind of
intercultural competency that will make
every person feel at ease when they
interact and engage with people from
different cultural traditions and from
people from different civilisational
streams we should see that kind of
cultural difference as an opportunity
for productive and creative transactions
and not as a threat of anybody's
identity the second set of outcomes our
education system should produce is deep
knowledge and understanding of other
countries
regions and of processes that are global
in nature whether those are + processes
related to global climate change to
trade to global risk and security to
economic development to poverty
alleviation around the world and the
third set of things that glow that
schools should do to prepare students
for global civility is to promote the
development of foreign language
capabilities in the 21st century every
person around the world should be able
to speak and to think in at least one
other language beside the language of
that is native in the country where they
were born we have a lot of good practice
and very many good efforts around the
world on how to do these things but many
of those are of a very small scale they
reach a fragment of the population and
we run the risk that the development of
global competency will represent the
next divide the next equity divide
between those who have been prepared to
understand and participate in this new
global order and those who have been
left behind and the creation of those
gaps and the maintenance of those gaps
presents a real risk to political
stability to equitable development and
to human development around the world so
what we need are initiatives of a broad
scale led by supranational institutions
and by governments to democratize the
opportunity to develop that skill set
thank you for your question